so obviously this finale was a wild wild
ride i want to know what was your
reaction when you read this on paper
like what was your action when you first
read the script
the well obviously the shootout between
the feds and fesco and ashtray stood out
you know
[Music]
please don't
it's funny espn picked up us uh you know
and they're pretty mainstream but this
just sort of speaks to how
i guess mainstream euphoria has become
um espn posted a shot of is there any
athlete as fearless as this guy it was a
shot of ashtray
it's a little 13 year old yeah little 13
year old
that's amazing now when you were filming
season two did you think that cal would
make a return by the end especially in
the finale because obviously as an
audience we weren't sure
i don't know my contract indicated i'd
make a return i didn't
[Music]
i didn't know you know it's a
cliffhanger i don't know i didn't know i
was getting arrested
you didn't we'll see cal live and direct
from folsom county prison
that's that's the spin-off i'm hoping
for i want to know what life behind the
bars is like for cal just nate and cal
behind glass
talking to each other through a phone
you know you make that joke but i can
see that scene playing out and i could i
feel like that would be actually some
quality television sir that's great but
how many episodes would i be in we could
do that for like two
i want to talk about that confrontation
between nate and cal nate don't do this
i i'm begging you don't do this you are
who you are
i don't think you're ever gonna change
what was that like for you to act
opposite jacob in those scenes i love
acting on opposite jacob that's my dude
yeah he and i have a pretty good
connection um
he's very present you know jacob's a
really solid actor he's a he's a dynamic
actor as well um
but uh
we
we have a solid connection and that
scene just kind of played out it seemed
effortless i don't know what it looked
like
um
the final product but it seemed pretty
effortless at the time
um and it felt natural it felt like this
was kind of the sort of the natural
evolution of how this sort of
relationship between father and son
would go what do you think of me and cal
where they landed by the end of the show
you know i'm glad i got to really
genuinely express how i felt about
myself
you know there's a lot of stuff going on
there and there's there's there's a ton
of stuff to unpack but at the end of the
day it's my blood it's my son i love him
you know and i got the opportunity to
acknowledge that i had failed him as a
father
and that i really do love him and you
know that whatever's going on with him
you know we're gonna figure out
we'll figure out you know it may be
figured out from the shoe program of
pelican bay
but it's going to be figured out do you
think nate did the right thing having
cal arrested
i don't know i don't want to be arrested
but right you know i i think the
circumstances were a little
i think there was a lot of latitude
there in the circumstances under which
cal would be arrested
you know he the
jules told him that she was 22.
he went through the sort of protocol he
goes through to make sure the person is
of age and
you know
a sound mind and body and
you know she she fooled him
uh
that said
you know it was illegal
it is illegal and amoral and all the
other stuff so
you know you never want to have your son
called the cops on you right
um so it was kind of jarring that it
came from him
but you know maybe it's a statement
maybe he's just teaching me a lesson
maybe who knows
maybe he doesn't go through with it
maybe he doesn't turn over the usb drive
talk to me about filming this past
season any fun memories on be on set
with your co-stars uh in between all
these intense dark story lines
we're pretty mellow you know
uh
you know i work a lot with jacob so we
just kind of kick it and talk craft and
books that we've read and and you know
if you leave your phone out he will
steal it and take selfies
yeah i wish i had my phone on me i'd
show you some of the selfies he took
so you got a collection now i've got a
collection of jacob lordy selfies in my
phone
i love it
well you know it's been quite a quite a
ride for cal this season too do you have
any favorite scenes or moments of
getting to play him
oh i loved being able to
to
come out to my family and sort of dress
them down and and
leave the house in in a in a
dumpster fire of a
right
i have raised you
i am your father
i know nothing about you
that's not true
i know that you're angry i mean you
dress them down but you also just
yourself down sir
that's true
i did half the monologue with my penis
out that is true i mean
come on that is that that's the gift
that keeps on giving i feel like that
scene right there it just kept getting
more wilder and wilder and wow yeah that
is a challenge for the actor i do want
to ask you about that scene there was a
moment where cal takes down like the
family portrait right off the wall
did it look like there was a third kid
in that family picture am i mistaken
no in the picture there's a third kid
do we know about this third kid
maybe he was a cousin we were
babysitting that day the family shot we
don't want to leave him out i don't know
there's a third kid and it's a mystery
if there's been fan theories that elliot
might be kell's son dominic feik's
character what are your thoughts on that
i don't know he's the the age is correct
okay okay
i don't know i don't know what happened
to that kid yeah maybe he was a stray we
just picked up on the day i just i don't
know what happened to that kid obviously
you know with cal finally coming out to
his family and himself really at the end
of the season did you think he was on
the path to finding happiness it should
look like it even though he was living
out of a warehouse
i don't know if you call that that
gaggle of people he was hanging out with
at the end happiness well he was living
his truth you know
it was cal's happiness that's for sure i
mean i think he probably
was on the path to his happiness the
second he left that house right
like it was like a weight lifted off
their shoulders
absolutely i know uh you all know better
than anybody that euphoria fans have
been on quite the roller coaster ride
this past season i've had a lot of
emotional reactions to it you guys have
been memes and been trending every week
what has it been like to see kind of
that reaction from fans who have been
eating this up
i hear about it and it's great it's
great when people watch and talk about
the show you're working on you know it's
a luxury um
i i'm not so plugged into the social
media aspect of this show so i don't see
it's not it's it's not in my face as
much as it's probably for everybody else
okay
so you never saw the reactions from your
flashback episode well there was another
fan theory that the guy that cal you
know first crushed on which was his high
school bestie is patrick dempsey's
character from grey's anatomy
that would be strange
it'd be a crossover i don't think we'd
anticipate you know
abc and hbo having crossovers
i mean that'd be i i i was a stretch
it's a stretch you know obviously
the fact that cal is arrested does leave
things open-ended for season three uh do
you think we'll still see cal moving
forward have you heard anything have you
gotten a call yet about the next season
i don't know anything i just let sam do
his thing and i just kind of show up
that's sort of the protocol there
are you hoping we'll see more of cal
throughout next season though i'm pretty
sure you'll see more of cal throughout
next season okay
all right so what direction do you think
it's going
well we gotta find out if he's in jail
first if he's in jail we know the
direction it's going okay
um but who knows i don't know who knows
what goes on inside the mind of sam
levin
it's interesting i'll tell you that
it'll be interesting